adrian hauser on the bound big time
ground ball pitcher matching up for the
first time against the cubs no kidding
making uh start number five in his
career and first
this year we've been talking about
hauser how is good how good he's been
for a long stretch his last two starts
2-0 that's against st louis and
cleveland 15 innings nowhere in runs
only four hits allowed
that one's in the air center field
little jam shot and kane will make the
play and that's how the night begins
and schwendel just punches one to right
field this guy's been a hitting machine
has the highest batting average in the
majors since july 30
little q shot right over to escobar
third base
and there is out number two
[Applause]
on the first pitch drives one to center
field but too high kane's under it and
hauser puts up a zero in the first
inning
zach davies the veteran right-hander
he'll sink it it throws a good change in
occasional cutter occasional curveball
6-11 with 5.40
dra made 111 starts with the brewers
from 2015 through 2019.
long hits that hard left field
is there
that was hit right on the button
this is the center ortega drifting back
and he puts the squeeze on it back
pedals onto the track two away
slash the left half is there
a couple of line outs to left yellow
trichy davies gets them one two three
and wisdom scheduled against hauser
takes a walk there so houser walks the
lead off guy
contreras
retired
my drive good swing there and he hit
that hard around second out his way to
third is hat and they're at the corners
he's two for two one down let's see if
alfonso rivas the left-handed batter can
drive in the game's first run
on the ground that gets through base hit
happened to score
wisdom to third rbi single rebound so
the cubs strike first one nothing
just got enough of it to pull it into
the hole between first and second fifth
hit of the night for the cubs all
singles
rudder takes off from first that one
grounded to third off the glove of
escobar in to score his wisdom two
nothing eduardo escobar not able to come
up with that cleanly alcon for the
hitter
broken back
and that will fall for a hit
and the throw hits duffy rivas in to
score three nothing
alcantara comes through
the leadoff walk can come back to bite
you right and that's exactly
what has happened here in this fourth
inning
look out
did he get a piece of that no
and duffy's gonna come in to score
so a wild pitch and it's now
four-nothing
davey's on the ground coming home is
alcontra and
[Music]
oh my goodness a terrible throw by luis
urias one of those in between hops and
omar able to pick it and make the tag at
home plate it's a heck of a play
so wong escobar and yelich
and that's fair just inside the line
bounces off the side wall wall on his
way to second base with a double first
hit of the game for the brute crew oh
yeah just a thing of beauty by colton
long my goodness
as escobar a base hit to center field
wong will stop at third first and third
for milwaukee here to start this fourth
inning here's yelich two on quickly here
in the fourth inning a double and a
single
and yelich in the left field of base hit
long
cruises home three straight hits
four to one cubs and the brewers get it
going now here in the fourth inning does
not all four bases loaded
four consecutive base runners to start
the fourth inning nobody out here is
urias have been great with the bases
loaded this year
and
dumps one into left center down base hit
in the score escobar
yell it's right behind him
luis suryas delivers again
right back in it right off the label for
luis urias two more rbis for him
he comes up with a big knock fastball in
on his hands just enough strength to get
it into the outfield yelich with his
speed scored easily
base is loaded one out
and lorenzo kane coming up
back to second
play
alcantara to duffy and they get out of
it and they preserve
a one-run lead
back of the fifth inning frank
schwendell do up for the cubs
drilled in the air left field yelich
back back some more leaping god
frank de tanko's yard 5-3
his 14th of the year
you can't stop him
no not even adrian hauser who had not
given up a home run in a good long while
even hauser couldn't keep the tank down
davies will face a pinch hitter luke
maylie
and maylie dumps one into right field
death by paper cuts in this game right
now all the line drives are caught
into right field
melee to second base
here comes the pitch swing and a miss
strike three he gets escobar
one away
yelling
and now they're loaded cody hoyer comes
in and into a big spot he's going to
face omar narvaez with the bases loaded
and one out payoff pitch
hoyer with a big strike up
well here comes the man brewers one at
the plate with the bases loaded luis
urias two outs runners go reus takes
ball four
a bases loaded walk and the brewers are
within a run again another rbi for ureas
his third
boy you're able to get peterson and that
ends the ending
now 5-4 chicago oh got him nasty
breaking ball right there the slider
torinos
with an about face aaron ashby strikeout
number three so one down and here is
matt duffy
that's the other way and that's a base
hit it's a one out single for duffy who
sliced it into the opposite field nicely
he goes they got him picked off throw to
second and the throw kicks away
duffy racing for third and he's gonna
make it well done he went first move
vogel back with a terrible throw to
second and a swing at a miss he struck
him out
big k for aaron ashby
that's what he needed aspie deals oh he
got him a slider melee can't find it
discovers it secures it hitting over
ashby strikes out three maurice has had
a good night he's driven in three runs
uras into left field that's going to get
down
a base hit for luis urias his second of
the game
what a beautiful at-bat that was
and down he goes got him on three
pitches again two outs and here comes
daniel vogelback then ball four
vogelback walks for the third time not
even close
now the tying run is at second base and
in steps lorenzo kane
and kane on the first pitch a little
flare right field falling fast down base
hit and here comes maria's throw goes to
third and safe
tie game
that's a little jam shot on the first
pitch you know he likes the first pitch
i think in third base all the way pretty
close and david ross and the cubs want
to take a look at this play at third
base the call is
safe tie game
and ball four
maybe draws a four pitch walk
and here comes cold wong with a chance
to put the brewers on top here in the
eighth
wong in the center field a base hit
reyes will score
kane will score
colt long delivers in the clutch
seven to five brewers
as wong drives in a pair
pitching change dylan maples will come
on here rock with two outs and runners
at the corners
oh wow throws it to the screen takes a
big carom in the score
as wild of a wild pitch as you can have
and now it's eight to five
well josh hader is on to try and nail
this one down
that's a liner caught
right out of ryus
half in the air center field long run
for kane got a bead
got it four out number two
over to third goes ortega
2-2 pitch on the way
and he got him struck him out with a
slider
and the brewers win this one eight to
five
rock the magic number for the division
is four
magic number for a post-season berth is
three
you